[Musique]
le g7 une occasion extraordinaire pour
tirer les leçons de la pandémie et
reconstruire en mieux
la déclaration de boris johnson à
l'ouverture de la réunion des sept
grandes puissances mondiales à
cornouailles dans le sud de l'angleterre
au coeur des débats la crise sanitaire
liée aux copies de 19 à ce sujet un
milliard de doses de vaccin a été
annoncée à destination des pays les plus
pauvres les états unis tête du poing sur
la table et infligent des sanctions à 4
proche du président nicaraguayen daniel
ortega réaction suite à l'arrestation de
sept opposants politiques ces derniers
jours et à cinq mois de l'élection
présidentielle et sont accusées je cite
de vouloir vendre la patrie l'arrêt de
l'opération barkan ne signe pas pour
autant la fin de la lutte antiterroriste
pour la france
les forces tricolores qui sont engagés
devra laisser place à une force
internationale
son calendrier chez les différentes
modalités devraient être communiqués à
la fin du mois face à l'incertitude
sécuritaire certains demandent un débat
parlementaire
[Musique]
et
bonjour bienvenue si vous ne retrouvez
sur air france le rendez vous a été
donné ce vendredi à cournoyer dans le
sud ouest de l'angleterre coup d'envoi
ce vendredi du g7
un sommet de trois jours qui ambitionne
un retour rapide à la normale après la
pandémie notamment distribuant 1
milliards de vaccins anti qu'ovide ai
tiré les leçons de la pandémie sied ne
pas répéter certaines erreurs ce sont
les mots du premier ministre britannique
boris johnson
la chancelière allemande s'est pour sa
part prononcée pour un multilatéralisme
afin de relancer l'économie mondiale
angela merkel qui envisage même une
confrontation avec la russie mais aussi
avec la chine
il s'agit de savoir comment relancer
l'économie mondiale et je suis ravi bien
sûr que le président américain soit ici
pouvoir rencontrer joe biden pour la
première fois et bien sûr quelque chose
d'important car il représente
l'engagement en faveur du
multilatéralisme qui nous a fait défaut
ces dernières années c'est pourquoi nous
nous prononcerons avec force en faveur
du multilatéralisme y compris du métier
latéral isme fondée sur des valeurs ce
qui entraînera bien sûr une
confrontation avec la russie mais aussi
à certains égards avec la chine d'un
autre côté nous avons besoin de tout le
monde
nous voulons travailler ensemble en
particulier sur la protection du climat
et la biodiversité
le g7 alors des revendications en marge
du sommet international des centaines
d'activistes se sont mobilisés sur les
plages du sud-ouest de l'angleterre
la pandémie l'action climatique ou
encore la fiscalité autant de sujets
dangereux qu les militants souhaitent
imposer au débat des plus grands
dirigeants de la planète
une procession en signe de contestation
le vert pour la nature le bleu pour
l'eau haut en couleurs les membres de
l'association extinction rébellion ont
marché dans les rues du comté de
cornouaille avec plusieurs pancartes aux
slogans explicites effondrement de la
biodiversité changement climatique noyer
dont les promesses
les activistes n'ont pas manqué de faire
preuve d'ingéniosité dans leurs actions
coup de poing
[Musique]
l'action du titanic est une métaphore de
ce à quoi nous sommes confrontés ou les
ingénieurs de l'époque ont été ignorés
les scientifiques sont toujours ignoré
jusqu'à l'obsession
les politiciens nous certes un affreux
discours vert il y a eu beaucoup de
rires et de félicitations de tapes dans
le dos de coup de coude mais en fait les
gaz à effet de serre continuent
d'augmenter
les différents mouvements sociaux
écologistes à l'air notamment sur la
déforestation de la forêt amazonienne et
appelle à plus de responsabilité et
d'actions de la part des pays les plus
riches
crise écologique économique sanitaire
pour l'organisation caritative oxfam la
levée des brevets sur les vaccins doit
devenir une priorité pour les pays les
plus industrialisés en ligne de mire les
bénéfices engrangés par les entreprises
pharmaceutiques
nous avons créé neuf nouveaux
milliardaires du vaccin au cours des six
derniers mois
donc il ne s'agit pas de faire de
l'argent excessif mais de permettre aux
marchés de se développer et à d'autres
fabricants du monde entier de fabriquer
ces vaccins et de sauver des vies le
président américain qui a promis ainsi à
son arrivée en grande bretagne de
distribuer dans les prochains mois 500
millions de doses du vaccin fighter à
plus de 90 pays
réduire les inégalités dans le domaine
de la santé du travail
les activistes mobiliser également pour
une égalité des sexes
nous savons que très peu de femmes sont
dans et autour des politiques et des
prises de décisions sur ce qui est
nécessaire
nous appelons à l'action pour lutter
contre la violence à l'égard des femmes
et soutenir les organisations de femmes
à être dans les prises de décisions de
façon critique
une grande partie de ses militants
souhaitent la création d'assemblées de
citoyens afin de répondre aux
problématiques du futur fait parmi les
dirigeants du g7 figure joe biden le
président américain n'a pas fait le
voyage depuis les états unis uniquement
pour le sommet international
le locataire de la maison blanche doit
aussi rencontrer le 16 juin prochain en
suisse pour la première fois son
homologue russe vladimir poutine est les
deux hommes devraient évoquer plusieurs
sujets notamment le sort de l'opposant
russe alexeï navalni la biélorussie ou
encore la question du contrôle des armes
nucléaires
la rencontre prévue à genève devrait
nécessiter le déploiement d'un important
dispositif de sécurité
des mesures drastiques plus ou moins
appréciés par la population locale
moi ça me dérange pas parce que je pense
que c'est plutôt bien pour la ville
après c'est vrai que
le parc est fermé déjà depuis quelques
jours et puis l'arabe est fermé je suis
pas toute la journée
donc c'est peut-être trop tôt je sais
pas mais je pense que c'est une bonne
publicité pour la ville et puis ça lui
redonne son rôle un peu historique
d'endroits de rencontre j'habite juste
au dessus donc voilà on a quelques
petits changements d'habitudes
au contraire on a même notre truc est
plus tranquille mais a pas de voitures
twitter pat cox mais je pense oui c'est
important qu'il y de ce genre
d'événement et puis qui nous oblige à
nous remettre en question et je pense
que ces deux présidents ils ont sûrement
beaucoup de choses à se dire
j'aimerais qu'ils se rencontrent
quelques quelque part ailleurs
parce que il dérange beaucoup ici les
gens à genève
peut-être les bars se rencontrer céline
il pour ne pas déranger personne
c'est sa mère parce que vous voyez
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est bloqué le
bus que gus n'arrive pas ici peu
beaucoup de logements direction
l'espagne la campagne de vaccination
contre le coc vie de 19 bat son plein le
pays sort petit à petit la tête de l'eau
et annonce la réouverture des
discothèques et des bars musicaux pour
le 21 juin prochain mais sous certaines
conditions
leslie singh là notre reporter a
barcelone nous explique lesquels il sera
à nouveau possible de danser en
catalogne mais avec un masque les boîtes
de nuit ouvriront officiellement leurs
portes dès le 21 juin prochain dans la
région alors plusieurs mesures encadre
cette réouverture
les lieux pourront ouvrir jusqu'à 3h30
du matin et jusqu'à 30 minutes
supplémentaires seront accordées afin
que les clients puissent quitter les
lieux
comme on l'a dit sur la piste de danse
le masque est obligatoire il sera
interdit de le retirer et donc pour
consommer il sera obligatoire d'être
assis dans un espace habilité alors les
groupes de personnes devront être de 6
maximum en intérieur et de 10 maximum en
extérieur bien entendu la désinfection
des lieux est obligatoire et les entrées
devront être vendus en amont les boîtes
de nuit pourront accueillir que jusqu'à
50% de leur capacité d'accueil
habituelle mais c'est tout de même un
soulagement pour le secteur qui voit
enfin le bout du tunnel en catalogne les
discothèques sont fermés depuis le
premier confinement de mars 2020 même
s'il y avait eu une rapide ouverture
autorisé pendant quelques semaines l'été
dernier alors tous les quinze jours les
mesures seront actualisées en fonction
de l'évolution de la pandémie et de la
vaccination
le secteur espère déjà impatiemment
pouvoir rouvrir jusqu'au bout de la nuit
prochainement
situation politique tendue en algérie
avec l'arrestation de cette figure de
l'opposition
un coup de filet qui intervient à la
veille des élections législatives
anticipées qui fait tache parmi les
interpellés figurent karim tabbou
directeur d'une station de radio proches
du mouvement de contestation irak hassan
el qady autres journalistes et
directeurs de médias
ce dernier est accusé notamment de
diffusion de fausses informations à même
de porter atteinte à l'unité nationale
le point sur place avec notre envoyé
spécial à alger bassin chebbi les
algériens appelés aux urnes samedi pour
élire leurs députés pour ces élections
législatives anticipées rejetée par le
irak et l'opposition qui demandent un
changement radical du système politique
en place depuis l'indépendance du pays
c'était en 1962 malgré la démission du
président abdelaziz bouteflika en avril
2019 et l'élection du nouveau président
adelman jt boon en décembre 2019 les
manifestations n'ont pas faibli dans
l'ensemble du pays
là des enjeux principaux de ces
élections législatives sera de faire
revenir les algériens dans les bureaux
de vote et éviter le scénario des
présidentielles de décembre 2019 et
celui du référendum sur la constitution
en novembre 2020 qui avait connu des
records d'abstention avec 60 et 76 % de
non votants deux échecs pour le pouvoir
qui reste plus que déterminé à
poursuivre sa feuille de route
électoralistes quitte à ignorer les
revendications de la rue l'opposition
elle est fermement décidé à boycotter
ces élections comme une partie des
algériens
l'iran se prépare à l'élection
présidentielle les 18 et 25 juin
prochain plus de 59 millions d'électeurs
sont appelés aux urnes
miné par les sanctions américaines le
pays subit une crise majeure le
redressement de l'économie nationale
s'annonce donc comme la priorité du
prochain président lequel ne sera pas
hassan rohani le président sortant après
deux mandats à la constitution iranienne
lui interdit en effet de se présenter
françois tessier beach
dans le grand bazar de téhéran on ne
parle que de la vie chère et de la
hausse des prix acheter une peugeot 206
est devenu un rêve inaccessible
il faut payer 2 milliards de rials pour
un acheté une avant elle n'avalait 300
millions l'inflation que le gouvernement
du président sortant hassan rohani était
parvenu à ramener sous la barre des 10%
s'est envolé en même temps que la
monnaie nationale le rial s'effondrait
selon les prévisions du fonds monétaire
international elle devrait atteindre 39
% cette année je n'ai pas le moral
pour l'avenir on ne fait aucun projet on
vit au jour le jour en fonction de la
situation économique
pendant les années où j'ai travaillé
j'ai vu les conditions économique
empirer au cours des six ou sept
dernières années
je n'ai jamais vu pire c'est horrible
faisant la république islamique avait
pourtant renoué avec la croissance après
la conclusion à vienne de l'accord
international sur le nucléaire iranien
en 2015 mais le retrait des états unis
par donald trump en mai 2018 et le
rétablissement des sanctions américaines
ont plongé l'iran dans une violente
récession isolé du système financier
international
téhéran a perdu progressivement les
clients de son précieux pétrole privant
ainsi le gouvernement de l'essentiel de
ses ressources
le plus grand défi pour le prochain
président et de rétablir la confiance
dans le marché boursier sur les marchés
financiers lorsque la confiance est
perdue restaurer cette confiance est le
principal capital qui doit être injecté
dans ce marché et rétablir la confiance
sur le marché très difficile d'origine
nomade armor à ces schémas
les gens voient leur argent fondre
depuis neuf a dit moir plus le crack
sera long plus il faudra du temps pour
réparer les choses et ramener la
confiance
[Musique]
à lamballe l'économie sera donc l'enjeu
principal de l'élection présidentielle
des 18 et 25 juin prochains
mais l'économie également impactés par
les conséquences du coc u19 avec près de
3 millions de cas l'iran est le pays du
moyen-orient le plus touché pour sortir
de la crise les sept candidats font de
la levée des sanctions américaines la
priorité et milite pour un retour de
washington dans l'accord à bonn lacéré
mathy a même déclaré ce mercredi qu'en
cas de victoire il serait prêt à
rencontrer le président américain joe
biden
washington monte au créneau et séville
la maison blanche annonce des sanctions
contre 4 proche du président
nicaraguayen dans sa propre fille
conséquence d'une vague d'arrestations
d'opposants politiques dans le pays il
ya cinq mois de l'élection
présidentielle daniel ortega au pouvoir
depuis 2007 souhaite décrocher un
cinquième mandat
les précisions avec antoine nogier une
répression politique de plus en plus
forte
mais aussi des opposants de plus en plus
déterminés à quelques mois de la
présidentielle qui doit se tenir le 7
novembre le président daniel ortega qui
craint de ne pas être élu une quatrième
fois sur exploite la loi guillotine voté
en décembre 2020 cette dernière vise à
punir toute tentative d'ingérence
étrangère
l'homme est qu'à la wallonie copine à
nous les nicaraguayens sommes les seuls
à pouvoir avoir notre mot à dire et a
décidé de la marche de notre pays
il n'est pas possible que des pays ou
des états tiers des organisations
internationales qui ne sont pas
nicaraguayenne imposent leurs décisions
à un pays libre souverain et
démocratique comme l'état du nicaragua
un simple versement de fonds venus de
l'étranger dont bénéficie un grand
nombre de fondations et d'organisations
non gouvernementales peut justifier une
arrestation et un emprisonnement en une
semaine à quatre candidats à la
présidentielle accusé d'actes contre la
souveraineté et de tentative d'ingérence
étrangère ont été arrêtés ce mercredi
les partis d'opposition ont fait front
commun pour dénoncer les méthodes
en nommant le régime ne peut pas se
soustraire 6 millions de nicaraguayens
désireux de liberté ce n'est pas le
projet d'une seule personne
nous ne parlons pas ici de candidature
le régime a déjà démontré que même par
le biais d'un processus électoral truqué
il n'est pas prêt à se soumettre à la
volonté du peuple ce sont des actions
qui accentue l'insécurité juridique et
matériels que vivent tous les
nicaraguayens dans un pays que le
gouvernement a l'intention de
transformer en une vaste prison
nous ne nous excluons pas du scénario
électoral sachant pertinemment que nous
sommes tous exposés
c'est ce que je voulais dire en
conclusion nous allons continuer avec
celui qui reste les états unis qui
entretiennent depuis des années des
relations conflictuelles avec le
nicaragua ont imposé des sanctions
financières à la propre fille de daniel
ortega et à des hauts responsables à
proches du chef d'état
leurs éventuels avoirs aux etats-unis
sont gelés et l'accès au système
financier américain ne leur est
désormais plus autorisés comme le
démontrent ces sanctions il y a un prix
à payer pour les complices de la
répression les états unis continueront
d'utiliser des outils économiques et
diplomatiques contre les membres du
régime engagé dans cette vague de
répression
washington qui depuis 2018 ne cache pas
sa volonté de faire tomber daniel ortega
a récemment qualifié le président de
dictateur et appellent la communauté
internationale à en faire de même
écoutez toujours à ce sujet l'analyse de
teris galifi les spécialistes en
relations internationales le régime
maintenant il s'est momifié il est en
train de se creuser ce devenu une
affaire de famille le sur des gars neuf
enfants je crois un tueur eduardo petits
jeux 6 + 8 sont des conseillers du
gouvernement et ils sont installés dans
les grandes entreprises
là où les marges les plus élevées donc
ça devient assez comique on se croit on
se croirait dans l'egypte de moubarak
avant 2011
hélas il ne réside à inventer des lois
pour empêcher d'adhérer en vérité pour
empêcher l'exercice de la démocratie
valois notamment guillotine que vous
avez cités qui le 2020
et qui dit que toute toute critique du
gouvernement peut être prises considéré
comme le terrorisme ou l'atteinte à la
sécurité d'état américain m en dos et la
veste de la défense de la démocratie
entre guillemets même si je ne suis pas
anti américain gmail à bienne les
américains tiennent le même discours dur
et très de dictateurs km mais salma dont
l'arabie saoudite
au pérou le nouveau nom du président se
fait toujours attendre le candidat de
gauche pedro castillo désigné vainqueur
avec 50,2 pour cent des voix ne peut pas
encore prendre ses fonctions
et pour cause le recours de son
adversaire keiko fujimori qui conteste
sa défaite est toujours en cours
qu'importe le chef du parti pérou libre
et continue de clamer sa victoire et
appel je cite à ne pas jouer avec la
démocratie
je ne profiterai jamais d'un espace
démocratique pour effacer les dettes ou
nettoyer mes délits cela ne peut pas se
faire on ne peut pas jouer avec la
démocratie
[Musique]
merci au peuple péruvien pour cette
campagne nationale visant à regagner non
seulement les votes mais aussi de
redonner sa place à la patrie si cette
mission a pu être accompli aujourd'hui
il en sera ainsi
le peuple demande la justice il aura au
mali un nouveau gouvernement vient
d'être formé toujours avec des
militaires à des postes haut placés
annonce qui intervient alors que l'armée
française a déclaré avoir tué un haut
responsable d'al qaïda au maghreb
islamique responsable de l'assassinât de
deux journalistes français en 2013 et
ghislaine dupont et claude vers l'on
avait été enlevée et tuée alors qu'elle
se trouvait un reportage près de kidal
et c'est dans ce contexte un qu'emmanuel
macro ont annoncé la fin de l'opération
barkan mais il ne s'agit pas pour autant
d'un désengagement total la france
continue de lutter contre le terrorisme
dans le sahel mais d'une autre manière
comme ne l'expliquent florence par les
ministres des armées hier en annonçant
la fin de l'opération barkan le
président de la république a réaffirmé
avec force notre objectif au sahel
lutter contre le terrorisme aux côtés
des pays sahéliens avec nos partenaires
européens et américain pour la sécurité
des français et pour la sécurité des
européens
nous resterons engagés au sahel
oui l'opération barkan telle que nous la
connaissons aujourd'hui devra évoluer
pour plus d'agilité pour plus
d'efficacité pour mieux accompagner les
forces armées sahélienne une annonce qui
a vivement fait réagir à bamako écoutez
la réaction de quelques habitants si les
militaires français restent ici
arriveront-ils à travailler en toute
harmonie avec la russie nous voulons de
l'aide
nous ne pouvons pas avancer son la
france ils peuvent rester ici mais ils
doivent accepter de travailler avec la
russie
depuis que les français sont dans notre
pays
les morts sont nombreux on ne peut plus
aller à kita on ne peut plus aller à gao
on ne peut plus aller nulle part ils
disent qu'ils ont des drones mais les
drones ne font que prendre des photos il
ne nous dévoile pas la vérité sur leurs
réelles intentions
ils ne sont pas venus se battre pour
nous libérer et on ne voit vraiment
aucun avantage à cette coopération
le départ de la france est à notre
avantage car depuis qu'elle est là nous
n'avons vu aucune amélioration nous ne
vivons que dans la souffrance
quotidienne
chaque fois que nous nous réveillons
nous nous rendons compte que la
situation se dégrade de plus en plus
situation humanitaire dramatique en
ethiopie et particulièrement dans la
région du tigré la guerre est censé être
finie mais les habitants ne sont pas
pour autant soulagé et pour cause la
famine fait rage 90% de la population a
besoin d'une aide alimentaire d'urgence
l'onu tire la sonnette d'alarmé alors
que plus de 30 mille enfants risquent de
mourir de faim hélène masquelier la
famine est imminente dans le nord de
l'ethiopie
six mois après la fin de la guerre aux
tigres et la région est toujours
assiégée et si la zone est très fertile
les soldats présents sur place tu le
bétail et ordonne aux villageois de
cesser de cultiver la terre
résultat près d'un tiers de la
population fait désormais face à un
manque de vivres enfin rené on verra
comment ils étaient une vingtaine ils se
sont rassemblés autour de ma maison et
ont détruit toutes mes récoltes
je revois encore ma maison avant qu'elle
ne soit brûlé l'homme monsieur tout nous
avons dû fuir vers une autre zone
ils ont continué de se rapprocher et à
mettre le feu partout
ils ont brûlé tout ce que j'avais
sur place labourer et planté sont
devenus des actes de résistance des
centaines voire des milliers d'habitants
sont coincés derrière les lignes de
front où les barrages routiers militaire
les accès aux hôpitaux sont bloqués les
plus proches ont été pillés ou détruits
à deux heures de route de la ville de
mekele une petite clinique de ville a dû
accueillir 1,5 million de personnes pour
les nations unies
il s'agirait du pire problèmes de famine
que le monde ait connue depuis une
décennie
l'organisation dénonce le manque d'accès
à l'aide humanitaire auquel seul un
cessez le feu immédiat pourrait remédier
nous avons besoin d'un accès sans
entraves à ces zones que nous n'avons
pas pu atteindre jusqu'à présent nous
avons été confrontés à de graves
contraintes
nous avons été empêchés par des hommes
armés d'atteindre certaines zones
les accès doivent donc se libérer et
être facilitée pour ce faire nous
estimons qu'il devrait y avoir un cessez
le feu
nous souhaitons l'arrêt des combats ce
qui nous facilitera notre travail et
celui de nos partenaires sur le terrain
et accéder à ces communautés
l'onu estime que 350 mille personnes de
la région sont aujourd'hui confrontées à
la famine
un décompte qui pourrait bien dépasser
les 400 milles dans les prochains mois
si un accès n'est toujours pas autorisé
dans ces zones la réponse humanitaire se
fait de plus en plus pressante
près de 560 mille personnes ont
bénéficié d'une aide alimentaire la
semaine dernière soit 3,3 millions
depuis le début du mois mais il n'ya
plus préoccupant pour les nations unies
le gouvernement du tigre et réclame la
réinstallation imminente des personnes
déplacées par les combats dans la région
une mesure qui concernerait
près de deux millions de tigres et 1 et
qui diminuerait drastiquement le nombre
de vivre encore disponible en france au
chapitre politique les élections
régionales qui se profile à une semaine
du premier tour jean philippe dugoin
clément maire udi de mennecy et vincent
jean brin amer libre de l'haÿ les roses
tous les deux candidats sur la liste de
valérie pécresse en ile de france espère
pouvoir porter leur voix au niveau
national écouter notre vocation de mai
mais pas le remplacer qui que ce soit
mais bien d'exister et de faire en sorte
qu'un maximum de concitoyens au maximum
de français pensent différemment lui dit
c'est le parti de l'écologie c'est le
parti de jean-louis borloo
et pour vous c'est important de siéger
dans ces exécutifs régionaux pour porter
cette voie et cette différence qui est
la nôtre pour vallerand de saint-just
trésorier du rassemblement national et
candidat sur la liste de jordan bardella
en ile-de-france valérie pécresse est
plus dans la communication que dans
l'action
l'enjeu est de et de faire le plus haut
score possible
on ne peut pas mésestimer le fait que
les ip crèche a accompli du travail à la
tête de la région
mais elle est surtout dans la
communication et dans le conformisme
valérie pécresse
jordan bardella veut une région sur le
plan du développement économique
beaucoup plus stratège que qu'à l'heure
actuelle pour faire le pendant d'un état
stratège une région stratège
voilà je pense que nous serions beaucoup
plus à la tête de la région de chevron
beaucoup plus jeu offensif est beaucoup
plus directif que madame pécresse sur un
certain nombre de points et c'est la fin
de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
prochain point sur l'actualité
ce sera dans une trentaine de minutes
rester avec nous sur arte france
[Musique]